Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Cuando era pibe
uno de los juegos que más me gustaba
era sumergirme debajo del agua
y ver cuánto tiempo
podía aguantar sin respirar.
En general eran unos 10 o 15 segundos.
A veces llegaba a los 30.
Y cuando llegaba a los 40
¡me sentía un superhéroe anfibio!
Pero, obviamente, siempre volvía
a la superficie a respirar.
Últimamente siento
que hago algo parecido con el celular.
Juego a no mirarlo,
como cuando aguantaba la respiración.
Claro, no son unos segundos
ni unos minutos.
Son unas horas.
A veces cuando me voy de vacaciones
pueden llegar a ser un par de días.
Pero a la larga siempre vuelvo a mirarlo.
Y vuelvo porque el celular,
las redes y la web
no son solo herramientas tecnológicas,
sino que se han convertido
en el nexo a través del cual respiramos
el oxígeno digital.
Este oxígeno digital
es el aire que necesitamos
para habitar un contexto virtual
pero no por eso menos real en el que
sucede gran parte de nuestra vida:
el entorno digital.
El surgimiento de este entorno digital
es un cambio histórico fundamental.
Durante cientos de miles de años
los seres humanos fuimos nómades.
Subsistimos básicamente de la caza,
de la pesca y la recolección.
Vivimos condicionados fundamentalmente
por los fenómenos naturales
como las lluvias o las nevadas.
Hace aproximadamente unos 10 000 años
empezamos a desarrollar la agricultura
y nos volvimos sedentarios.
Y con el surgimiento de la
civilización urbana hace unos 5000 años
nuestra vida empezó a depender no solo
de lo que sucede en el entorno natural
sino también de lo que pasa
en el entorno urbano
como por ejemplo el estado
del tránsito o si se cortó la luz.
Yo hace 20 años que me dedico
a estudiar cómo nos informamos.
Hasta hace muy poco era muy común
escuchar en las entrevistas de
investigación que la gente me dijera
que una de las primeras cosas
que hacía al despertarse
era encender la tele o la radio
y escuchar rápidamente
cómo viene el tiempo y el tránsito.
O sea, tener un pantallazo del
entorno natural y del entorno urbano
antes de comenzar el día.
Hace unos años se empezó a agregar
cada vez con más frecuencia
agarrar el teléfono celular
--que suele estar en la mesita de luz--
y ver cuántos mensajes nuevos
hay en WhatsApp
y qué novedades hay
en las cuentas de Facebook,
de Twitter, de Snapchat, de Instagram...
todo eso desde que se fueron a dormir.
O sea, cada vez más empezamos nuestro día
con un pantallazo de los tres entornos
en los que sucede nuestra vida:
el natural, el urbano y el digital.
Durante el día miramos el celular
un promedio de unas 80 veces
antes de irnos a dormir.
Si a eso le sumamos la cantidad de tiempo
que pasamos con la compu
o incluso con la tablet
cuesta realmente encontrar un momento
en el que no estamos conectados.
Pero no es solo una cuestión de tiempo,
sino también de intensidad emocional.
Es muy común escuchar que el celular
se ha convertido en una parte del cuerpo.
Una mano más de la cual, por lo tanto,
cuesta mucho desprenderse.
Para una investigación que hicimos
con colegas en Argentina
hace un par de años entrevistamos
a más de cien personas
en distintos puntos del país.
Una de ellas nos contó que en un viaje,
yendo de una provincia a la otra,
cuando llegó a destino se dio cuenta
de que se había olvidado el celular.
Un pariente le dijo: "No te preocupes,
te lo alcanzo en un par de días".
Ahora, esta persona contaba
en la entrevista que aún sabiendo
que eran solo dos días de ausencia,
ella sin el celular sentía que se moría.
Ella sentía que se moría
porque lo que le faltaba
más que el celular era el oxígeno digital.
Este oxígeno digital es distinto
del que respiramos con nuestros pulmones.
Una diferencia clave es que
el oxígeno digital nos permite
respirar atmósferas múltiples
y diversas a la vez.
Como cuando participamos
de muchas interacciones
con distintos grupos de gente
que viven en lugares distintos
y todo esto a través
de redes sociales distintas.
Es como que estamos permanentemente
viendo y siendo vistos.
Hay una expectativa doble.
Por un lado sentimos que tenemos
un acceso casi permanentemente
--como una ventana abierta--
hacia la vida de los otros;
a lo que hacen, a lo que dicen,
incluso a lo que sienten.
Por otro lado, claro,
está la expectativa inversa.
Y nuestros contactos muchas veces
sienten que tienen derecho
a tener una ventana casi permanentemente
abierta hacia nuestras vidas.
Es como si el voyeur se cruzara
con el exhibicionista.
Tanta visibilidad atrae,
pero agota al mismo tiempo.
Nuestra sociabilidad se multiplica
y sentimos que
nos cuesta mucho desconectarnos.
Y cuanto más joven se es,
más cuesta esta desconexión.
En invierno de este año, una noche,
caminando por la Avenida Corrientes,
en pleno corazón porteño,
vi una escena que me impactó.
Fue una escena tristemente
antigua y moderna a la vez.
Eran un chico y una chica, muy jovencitos,
viviendo en la calle, a la intemperie
a merced de los fenómenos naturales
como hace cientos de miles de años.
Estaban sentados en un par
de silla desvencijadas.
Tenían enfrente una caja de cartón
grande dada vuelta
que hacía las veces de mesa,
mientras muchas otras cajas de cartón
apiladas a ambos costados
demarcaban de alguna manera
su espacio semiprivado en la vía pública.
Estaban cenando, juntos.
Y mientras comían miraban a un celular.
Eran jóvenes sin techo,
pero con conexión al entorno digital.
Esta escena sintetiza
uno de los hallazgos importantes
de nuestras investigaciones.
Y es que la pertenencia
a un grupo etario --la edad--
suele ser más importante
a la hora de entender y explicar
cómo habitamos el entorno digital
que el género
o, incluso, el nivel socioeconómico.
Y esto de alguna manera
marca el pasaje del siglo XX al XXI.
Ahora, que esto pase en un país
donde tres de cada diez personas
viven debajo de la línea de pobreza
es un fenómeno sociológico notable.
El paso del tiempo
es algo que nunca se detiene.
Todos los días envejecemos.
Lo que en un momento fue novedoso
va a dejar de serlo.
Y el recambio generacional es inexorable.
Entonces, si el paso del tiempo,
si la edad,
es lo que organiza cómo habitamos
el entorno digital
eso significa que vivimos
en una sociedad en movimiento
donde el cambio es tal vez
la única constante.
Esto nos genera incertidumbre.
A veces nos preocupa.
Otras incluso nos da ansiedad.
¿Cómo va a ser el futuro?
¿Por qué si yo estoy acostumbrado a algo
esto posiblemente vaya a cambiar?
Y es por esto que, al menos
en parte, yo creo que
muchas veces se habla del entorno digital
evocando escenarios apocalípticos.
Como por ejemplo,
la tormenta de noticias falsas
que va a destruir el edificio
de la Democracia.
Pero una sociedad en movimiento
es una sociedad en la cual
es también más posible vivir cambios,
transformaciones sociales,
que antes eran mucho menos probables.
Voces que fueron históricamente marginadas
y que tampoco tuvieron lugar
en los medios tradicionales
han recientemente
no solo logrado hacerse oír
sino también dar impulso
a importantes reformas colectivas.
Hace tres años un tuit dio el puntapié
inicial al movimiento Ni Una Menos.
Desde aquel entonces las activistas
se han apropiado del entorno digital
para organizarse, visibilizar
sus reclamos, y empoderar
a importantes sectores de la ciudadanía.
No es por las redes que
este movimiento social existe.
Ni obviamente existe solo en las redes.
Pero sin el entorno digital
sería mucho más difícil imaginar
su existencia y su fuerza.
Esto no significa que las noticias falsas
no se viralicen en las redes.
Sí, muchas veces se viralizan.
Pero significa que
estas tendencias negativas
existen junto con las posibilidades
de reforma social
que vemos en casos tan esperanzadores
como Ni Una Menos.
Y es en la lucha entre estas
tendencias negativas y positivas
que se juega gran parte del futuro
del entorno digital.
Y tal vez de la sociedad en su conjunto.
Hoy leemos en los libros de Historia
cómo fue el surgimiento
de la civilización urbana
y su evolución a lo largo de los siglos.
Y muchas veces a raíz
de esas lecturas nos preguntamos
qué hubiera pasado con nuestra sociedad
si las ciudades se hubieran diseñado
y construido de maneras distintas.
Pero nosotros somos los pioneros
del entorno digital.
Son nuestros descendientes quienes
van a leer en libros aún a ser escritos
cómo fueron estos años clave
en la formación del entorno digital.
Y muy posiblemente
se hagan preguntas bastante similares
a las que nosotros nos hacemos
cuando leemos la historia de las ciudades.
¿Qué les gustaría que sus nietas,
sus bisnietos, sus tataranietas,
leyeran acerca de los inicios
del entorno digital?
Y ¿qué lugar quisieran tener Uds.
como sujetos y protagonistas,
no solo como espectadores,
en escribir esta historia del futuro?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)